um row four please ingrid
hello i'm julie
it's very motivating for me to listen
and learn from you and you look so
passionate about what you're doing about
your work
my question to you is
like more in the daily work
what what what motivates you the most in
your daily work
what what what
motivates you motivates me
you know the hope that i can
help somebody solve a problem or
alleviate suffering or
find a way to a better life i mean i i
get just as
uh motivated by
you know trying to connect up
uh somebody after the earthquake in
haiti with
their relatives who were looking for
them and we put together a
a cell phone
uh
network uh to be able
to reconnect people as i do
uh trying to
you know push forward on solving uh
issues arising out of
the arab awakening or
the
violence in central america or all the
other
issues that i work on every day so it's
both the
you know the big picture issues that we
work on and try to make progress on
but
what you need when you're working on
what often are intractable problems
are some of the day-to-day successes
that
will never make headlines but which are
you know get gratifying and you know
because in the position you're in you
can make things happen so that's very
motivating to me
let's go over here please
my name is ina i have a question about
being a woman in high in the highest
level of foreign policy
do you believe that it changes foreign
policy outcomes when there are more
women around the negotiating tables and
if so how
i've thought a lot about that and
i i don't know that there's any
empirical evidence
that would prove that but
i certainly feel it
most of the time i'm the only woman
at the negotiating table
and i do try to raise issues
and i always talk about women's rights
and i always tell
every audience and
every
male leader i'm with well you knew i was
going to say this but what what is this
going to mean for women and for children
and
when i work with other
high-level women in international
affairs you know like
the high representative of the european
union uh kathy ashton
there's a shorthand in a way
uh as to what we're trying to achieve
and how we can perhaps
work together to do that
i also am
a very
strong believer that
the women i know who have achieved
the head of state or head of government
generally not
always but generally
you know will be
more
responsive to
a lot of the human needs
when
my friend
ellen johnson sirleaf became president
of liberia and inherited
a country ruined by
horrific civil war and war lordism
she was elected because the market women
in
the country
christian and muslim alike
said enough of war
and literally
forced the men to the negotiating table
and there's a wonderful documentary
about this called pray the devil back to
hell
if you can pull it up on the internet
because it was a perfect example of
women saying enough
or when there was a recent
negotiation over
how to end the long conflict in darfur
the men in the room spent days arguing
over who would get
territory around a certain river
and a woman outside the door said that
river's been dry
for years
because it wasn't men that went looking
for water it was women
and so there are so many insights that i
view as coming from practical everyday
experience
uh that you know men bring their own but
women bring our own
and i don't see how we can make the best
decisions unless there is
literally a meeting of the minds which
is why i really welcome more women
involved in these discussions and i
think the
the substance is more likely to reflect
the everyday needs of the people who are
most at risk in the resolution of any
kind of dispute
yeah let's go to the left back please
hello madam i'm judy um from a
communication student from ruskin
university
um my question is right
in this conversation right now um
you started by um acknowledging and
complementing um
a lot of the the strengths here in
denmark and our society here um
when you
recently it was a few years ago in the
last government here um there was a
danish female um minister of foreign
affairs
and i guess representatives from canada
russia and denmark in the states that
had a discussion about the arctic area
this lady in this situation made a
decision to prioritize family
versus that meeting um i'm sure people
in your positions are always having to
make difficult choices i wanted to ask
you
does work life
balance exist on your level of
leadership
or i mean as a role model for future
generations is it something we should
just say that okay
throw it out the baby with the bathwater
if you want to be at that level your
husband has to be your wife or
can you say anything about um
making those kind of difficult
situations and
yes yes
well
um
i
look there's a double standard for women
in the public eye that's just a fact and
it's
it's something that's getting somewhat
better because people are more conscious
of it but
um
it is
certainly
a challenge for
um
young women with
small children
uh or with teenagers which sometimes
feel like the same if you're a mother
um
so when you are trying to really balance
your family obligations with
any work but particularly work in the
public eye particularly at
a very high level of
stress and involvement
it takes enormous amounts of
organization
it takes very supportive family members
in particular
your spouse
to work out what the scheduling and all
of that will be
but i would hate to see any young woman
who wants to have a family decide she
could not do that because she also wants
to have a career i think that would be
a terrible mistake that's just me
personally if you don't want to that's
your choice and i fully support it but
if you want to and you think you can't
do it or you can't manage it because you
also want a career
you have to accept the fact you're going
to have to make some kind of
accommodation
if you wish to
be the best
mother you can be
as well as
fulfill the obligations of your
profession
and i will be very honest with you i
mean
when my daughter was young
my husband was the governor of arkansas
and i practiced law but nothing at the
level or intensity
of what i did after she was older and
that was my choice i never i have a lot
of
women whom i know who
are the most superb balancers in the
world and they manage everything but i
knew that for me
uh focusing on my daughter during those
early years was something i wanted to do
and that i believed was
my first
priority
so as she got older
unfortunately you know
you're not as needed um
i used to sit around the white house
waiting for a sighting um
you know you you know i did have a lot
more time and a lot more freedom and
could run for the senate could run for
the presidency could be a secretary of
state um
that is one of the advantages of being a
woman in the 21st century
is if you take care of yourself uh you
have a lot of options that our mothers
and grandmothers could have never
dreamed of so i i think you've got to
figure out your own balance
but don't make a decision that you can't
do one or the other
until you try to see if you can find
that balance
now you mention it madam secretary that
you ran for president i did yeah
and that leads me to my
i think if we ran a quick vote in here
you would be
elected
well my question is you said in january
that you're not going to continue as a
secretary of state even though president
obama would get a second term and
that leads me to it's actually a double
question what are you going to do then
um and can you rule out completely that
you're going to run for president in
2016. yes i i have said that many times
i'm really looking forward
to
you know pursuing
other interests that i have i've been so
honored to serve
with president obama and
feel
incredibly
uh
privileged that i served at a time with
so much change the chapters yet to be
written about what the conclusions of
all this change
uh will turn out to be
but i also think that for me
i've been um
you know at the highest levels of
american political life for 20 years and
i would like to be able to just
take a long walk i'd like to be able
to
just travel
without having a lot of official
meetings associated with it
i'm just looking forward to
exhaling
and seeing what
you know what else lies ahead and i've
always been
actively involved in philanthropic work
uh not for profit work i want to
continue doing that with an emphasis on
obviously women and children for me
do some writing some speaking i'm
looking forward to it and
who knows what i'll end up doing but i'm
excited by the possibilities and when
you come back to denmark as a private
citizen we would all be happy to give
you holiday um possibilities would you
please advise exactly we would we will
all of us because i've looked at the map
and there's so many interesting places
that uh you all are from uh i was
talking to the the foreign minister
about that earlier and i had the great
honor of being received by uh her
majesty the queen and you know this is
just to me a fascinating country and so
i am going to come back at some point uh
incognito so if you see me on the street
go i know that's you
we're running a little close to the end
madam secretary but if you're up for it
one more question from the crowd let's
go let's try if it's physically possible
to go to row two
if you have a long arm
you have
very good
hello madam secretary thanks so much for
doing this
my name is emma and i study at the
university at the copenhagen
my question is regarding
female reproductive health in the
american health care system i know
you're very passionate about health care
but this is a more personal question
recently there's been a lot of debate
about
female reproductive health care not just
on
the presidential election level but also
in senate and congressional hearings
um it's been pretty shocking especially
seeing as roe v wade was so so long ago
and it's seen as a war we already fought
and now it feels like we're fighting it
again
do you think that
this these these debates being held
diminishes america's right to position
position itself as a leader on civil
rights and be seen as such i think
well you're right there there has been
and continues to be
a debate over abortion coming out of
the roe v wade decision of course
preceding that but
most
intensely since then
and there has been a very
concerted effort to
undermine what we call a woman's right
to choose
which i
have always supported
but it the debate has now taken another
turn which is to
uh make contraception
uh debatable
and that to me is really a uh
development
the debate is over whether
the
comprehensive health care reform that
president obama
championed and that was passed by the
congress
will include
insurance for women's reproductive
health
including contraception
and
the evidence on the benefits for
contraception
is overwhelmingly
clear
in the way that it does protect women's
health it
does prevent unwanted pregnancies
and
also enables women who shouldn't for
physical or mental reasons become
pregnant um avoid doing so
you know it shouldn't be
debatable but the debate is over whether
taxpayer dollars should go
to subsidize health plans that provide
contraception
and it is a political debate i i don't
think it
should or does affect
our
strong
reputation and support for civil rights
but it
is something that we're going to have to
continue to contest within our political
system
and
you know it is troubling to me because
um
it seems
so
uh focused on poor women
because
middle class and
upper income women
will provide for their own health care
but if you're
a young student if you're
a working
mother if you are
someone who
doesn't have the financial means to
afford
contraception the first thing is to be
covered by
health care insurance which is the
democratic party position
that covers everyone and then to have
what you need at
every stage of your life included
so it's um
it's reflective of an ongoing debate
within our political system and we're
going to have to as you have debates
within your political system keep
working it out and in a democracy
hopefully people will make the right
decision
that's it guys
thanks for sorry all your